>> Jesse: PRESIDENT BIDEN
SPEAKING TO REPORTERS JUST A FEW
MINUTES AGO, LET'S WATCH.
>> YOU SPEND A LONG TIME
TOGETHER, WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME
WITH THE FAMILY AND WE JUST
TALKED ABOUT THE ONE YEAR
ANNIVERSARY AND THAT EVERY
ANNIVERSARY, YOU ARE HAPPY
PEOPLE REMEMBER BUT IT TAKES A
LOT OF COURAGE TO GO THROUGH.
THEY HAVE BEEN WONDERFUL AND I
HAVE SPOKEN WITH THE NEGOTIATORS
AND I'M HOPEFUL THAT SOMETIME
AFTER MEMORIAL DAY WE WILL HAVE
AN AGREEMENT ON THE GEORGE FLOYD
LEGISLATION.
AND I THINK THEY WERE VERY
PLEASED WITH THE TIME WE SPENT
TOGETHER.
WE SPENT A LONG TIME, ALMOST A
COUPLE HOURS.
THE FIRST THING SHE DID WAS
RANTED AND THREW HER ARMS AROUND
ME AND GAVE ME A BIG HUG, SHE
ALSO LOVED THE IDEA, SHE SAID
"I'M REALLY HUNGRY," HAVING
SNACKS, MY WIFE AND CHILDREN
GAVE HER SOME ICE CREAM, AND I
THINK SHE HAD CHOCOLATE MILK,
I'M NOT SURE.
I SHOWED THEM AND WE SPENT TIME,
SHOWING THEM AROUND.
AROUND THE WHITE HOUSE.
GAVE THEM ALL LITTLE MEMENTOS.
A GREAT PICTURE OF GIANNA, WHEN
I WENT DOWN TO THE FUNERAL.
B2 THAT WAS THE PRESIDENT
TALKING ABOUT MEETING WITH THE
FAMILY OF GEORGE FLOYD ON THE
ANNIVERSARY OF HIS DEATH, HAVING
SOME TROUBLE HEARING THAT AUDIO
SO WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE WITH
"THE FIVE" HERE.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" JUST
PUBLISHED THE MOTHER OF ALL PUFF
PIECES BOASTING ABOUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S WORKOUT
ROUTINE AND DESIRE TO ESCAPE THE
WASHINGTON BASEL, THEY ALSO DID
SOME HARD-HITTING REPORTING ON
HIS FAVORITE GATORADE FLAVOR,
ORANGE.
AND HIS COOKIE PREFERENCE.
CHOCOLATE CHIP.
HERE IS JUST A SMALL SAMPLE.
"BIDEN BEGINS HIS MORNINGS WITH
A WORKOUT THAT OFTEN INCLUDES
LIFTING WEIGHTS AND MEETS
REGULARLY IN PERSON WITH A
TRAINER.
DURING THE 2020 CAMPAIGN HE
BIKED REGULARLY ON BOTH
TRADITIONAL BIKE AND THE PEL.
HIS CURRENT PREFERENCES ARE
SOMETHING OF A STATE SECRET,
HOWEVER, AND THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS WILL CAN'T GET ENOUGH.
>> WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S HEALTH
REGIME.
WE HEAR HE'S LIFTING WEIGHTS,
WHAT SORT OF WAIT TO SEE LIFTING
AND WHAT HAPPENED TO HIS PELOTON
BIKE, DID HE BRING IT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE?
>> I HAVE NOTHING TO READ OUT ON
THE PRESIDENT'S EXERCISE REGIME
BUT I CAN TELL YOU, HAVING
TRAVELED WITH HIM A FAIR AMOUNT,
SOMETIMES HE'S HARD TO KEEP UP
WITH.
>> Jesse: WE HAVE THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE GEORGE FLOYD
DEATH, CHINA COVERING UP THE LAB
SITUATION, WE HAVE RUSSIA
HACKING OUR PIPELINE, BUT IT HAS
DONE NOTHING ABOUT IT, HE LET
THE OTHER PIPELINE GO TO
GERMANY, INFLATION AND IS
GETTING ASKED ABOUT PELOTON,
DANA.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
>> Dana: YOU FORGOT THE
BORDER.
HOW COULD YOU POSSIBLY, JESSE,
YOU OF ALL PEOPLE.
NOT TO MENTION OUR PROBLEMS OF
TAIWAN END OF CHINESE OVER THERE
AFTER THAT LAST SEGMENT, WE'RE
PROBABLY GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE
AN EMERGENCY MEETING SOMEWHERE.
IF YOU ARE THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY AND YOU GET A QUESTION
LIKE THAT, HOME RUN, EASY, THEY
ARE KIND OF FUN AND THE REPORTER
KNOWS HOW TO GET CLICKS BECAUSE
PEOPLE LIKE TO READ ABOUT THESE
TYPE OF THINGS.
THEY LIKED TO DO IT WITH OBAMA
BOTH PRESIDENT TRUMP IT WAS THE
OPPOSITE.
HE LIKES HIS STEAK WELL DONE.
BY THE WAY, SO DO I.
HE DID WAS CATCH UP, HEATS IT
WITH FRENCH FRIES AND HAS A
TERRIBLE DIET, THOSE OF THE
THINGS THAT REPORTERS WOULD
WRITE ABOUT AND CLICK ON.
THIS KIND OF THING HAPPEN.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE DOES, I'M
GOING TO GUESS, GREG, HE
PROBABLY DOES HIIT HILLS.
>> Greg: LOW IMPACT.
ME TOO I JUST FOUND OUT HE
DOESN'T DO CABLE NEWS EXCEPT FOR
"MORNING JOE" BEFORE JOE IS
ALMOST AS GOOD SHAPE AS THE
ILLEGAL ALIENS SPRINTING ACROSS
OUR BORDER.
IT'S HARD TO CONJURE UP STRONG
FEELINGS ABOUT JOE BIDEN AND
THAT'S A SECRET SUPERPOWER WHICH
ALLOWS THEM TO BE SUCH AN
EFFECTIVE CONDUIT FOR FAR LEFT
POLICIES, THE SQUAD.
PEOPLE HATED TRUMP SO MUCH THAT
THEY ARE OVER SCRUTINIZED
EVERYTHING HE DID TO A POINT OF
ACTUALLY HALLUCINATING THINGS
THAT HE DIDN'T DO.
BUT WITH JOE HE'S JUST SO JOE,
HE JUST GOES ALONG TO GET ALONG,
THE MEDIA IS PLEASED AS PUNCH
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE TO WORK
THAT HARD, THEY CAN SLEEP AT
NIGHT AND THEY ARE GETTING THE
FAR LEFT POLICIES AND IT REALLY
IS, IT COMES DOWN TO, IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO LIKE YOUR
PRESIDENT.
SURE YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
INFLATION, A TERRIBLE BORDER AND
RAMPANT CRIME, 20 CITIES IT
HASN'T BEEN SEEN SINCE THE
1960s, WE ARE SEEING EXPANDING
UNEMPLOYMENT, MEDIA-DRIVEN
RACIAL CONFLICT BUT FOR
GOD'S SAKES THERE'S NO TWEETING
AT MIDNIGHT, WHAT A TRADE-OFF, I
AM SO HAPPY I CAN SLEEP.
B2 KATIE, MY FAVORITE PART OF
THE STORY AS THEY SHOWED PART OF
HIS SCHEDULE, AT 9:50:00 A.M.,
HE WAITS AROUND FOR HIS CHIEF OF
STAFF.
HE WAITS, THE PRESIDENT, FOR HIS
CHIEF OF STAFF.
>> Katie: JOE BIDEN IS WAITING
FOR THE ACTUAL PRESIDENT, THE
PRIME MINISTER OF THE
UNITED STATES, HE WAITS FOR HIS
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS TO RUN THE
SHOW.
FIRST OF ALL, WHY IS THE PRESS
NOT DEMANDING THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE PHYSICIAN COME OUT
AND GIVE A REAL, DETAILED
EXPLANATION OF THE PRESIDENT'S
HEALTH?
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE THAT
ESPECIALLY AFTER THE PRESIDENT
FELL UP THE STAIRS TWICE WHICH
COULD HAVE BEEN A REALLY SERIOUS
PROBLEM.
BUT I'M GLAD TO KNOW THAT HE IS
A TRAINER, HE CAN DO HAND-EYE
COORDINATION DRILLS TO MAKE THAT
NOT HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> Jesse: ANOTHER JUICY NUGGET
WITH THIS THING, HE HAS LUNCH
WITH KAMALA ONCE A WEEK, THEY
SEE MONTAGES OF PICTURES OF
THEMSELVES THAT THEY HAD TAKEN
OF THEM DOING EVENTS THROUGHOUT
THE WEEK.
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
SAY.
>> Jesse: YOU NEITHER.
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
KIND OF ROOM THEY ARE AND WHEN
THEY HAVE THAT MONITOR UP NEXT
TO THEM.
>> Dana: THE PRIVATE DINING
ROOM.
>> Juan: DO THEY HAVE A BIG
MONITOR LIKE THAT?
>> Dana: IT'S LIKE A BIG TV
SCREEN.
ANYWAY, I THINK THE PRESH GUSHES
OVER NEW PRESIDENTS REGULARLY,
THINK ABOUT GEORGE WASHINGTON
AND THE CHERRY TREE, LEGENDS GET
BUILT, DOLLEY MADISON, THE
GREATEST HOSTESS EVER.
WITH TRUMP, BY THE WAY, IVANKA
AND JARED WITH A POWER COUPLE
FOR EVERY COVER.
RONALD REAGAN HAD IT FOR SIX
YEARS BUT HE WAS A PRO UNTIL IT
WENT AWAY BUT YEAH, I THINK THIS
IS WHAT HAPPENS RIGHT BEFORE
THEY START TAKING OUT THE LONG
KNIVES FOR YOU.
>>